- Some contact lens brands say
that it's okay to sleep in them,
but as a general rule, it's really not.
My name is Dr. Irina Belinsky.
I am an eye surgeon specializing
in oculoplastics and ocular oncology.
Contact lenses are safe,
but they're safe if you take
care of them appropriately,
and part of good contact lens hygiene
is not sleeping in your contact lenses.
Think of the contact lens as
foreign material in your eye.
It's sort of like a sponge,
and to be comfortable,
the contact lens needs to be moist,
so, it absorbs moisture from your eye,
and it can also trap bacteria,
and so, it's very important
to take your contact lenses out
to clean them periodically.
Leaving them in when you sleep
can cause an eye infection
that can sometimes be really, really bad.
A lot of the infections can be mild
and go away with antibiotic eye drops,
but some infections can
be really, really severe,
and even if they go away,
they can cause scarring
of the surface of your eye,
which is the cornea,
and that scar can cause
sort of a permanent change in your vision.
Sometimes an infection can be devastating,
and it can completely cause the eye
to scar to the point
that someone might need
a corneal transplant or
lose vision completely.
Really serious blinding kind of infections
related to contact lens
wear are rare, fortunately.
If they were common,
then nobody would ever
wear contact lenses.
So, they are exceedingly rare,
and they usually have to do with really,
really bad contact lens hygiene.
So, good contact lens hygiene
has to do with a few things.
One, knowing if your contact lens needs
to be changed every
month or every two weeks
and trying to stick to that,
even if you have to put a little reminder
in your calendar.
The more common thing that we see
is just contact lens overwear.
The cornea gets devoid of oxygen.
So, a contact lens does
start to break down over time
so it doesn't have a smooth surface.
It's gonna form
micro-breakdown kind of edges,
and the contact lens will also dry out.
I mean, your eye just
doesn't have enough moisture
to keep a contact lens in there forever.
If you think of the
contact lens as a sponge,
like the sponge in your kitchen,
you have to clean it every so often,
and you might even have to
replace it every so often,
because it just doesn't
do the job right anymore.
A contact lens can become kind of folded
and entrapped in the
eye underneath the lid,
so, I have seen that
where patients come in
with chronic red eye,
and you look around very carefully
and sometimes, and this is also rare,
but you can actually
extract a contact lens
that has probably been there for months.
It can happen if you put it in wrong.
It can happen if you sleep in it.
It can happen if you don't take it out,
or if you forget to take it out.
Take your contact lenses out.
Don't leave them in.
Take them out every day.